hello everyone and welcome back to the
continuation of the first match it's
alireza ferrugia vs magnus carlsen and
if you're wondering why why they're
playing a second game is because here in
norway if the classical game ends in a
draw then the players played the
armageddon game right away after the
classical game finished and the player
who had the white pieces in the
classical game will have the cla the
white pieces in the armageddon game and
when the colors will be reversed in the
second part of the tournament everything
applies the same so now it's uh
the player with the white piece has uh
10 minutes on the clock the player with
the black pieces has seven minutes on
the clock uh and the player with the
white pieces has to win the game if
magnus gets a draw then he wins the
armageddon game and he uh wins their
first encounter here winning uh
an extra half a point so they both get a
full point for a draw uh but uh if
alireza wins for example he will get an
additional half point for winning the
armageddon game and they also get a one
second increment but only starting as of
move 41. uh so let's let's check it out
it's really really a crazy game uh so
alireza with the white pieces again
opens with e4 sorry about that uh like
he did in the classical game magnus
again replies with c5 we have knight to
f3 knight the c6 and the bishop to b5 so
again we have the niz medina rosolimo
attack we have e6 castles and knight to
g to e7 now it is a continues with rook
to e1 but magnus doesn't continue with
knight to g6 like he did in the
classical game but place b6 and now he's
saying he wants to get this early
fianchetto of the light square bishop
and now there are some games where c3
was played but alireza strikes with the
d4 right away and it is now already as
of move six that we have a completely
new game uh magnus captures on d4 we
have knight captures on d4 and bishop to
b7 uh developing the light squad bishop
by fianchettoing knight to c3 and now a6
again asking all it is what are you
going to do with this bishop but now he
talks it back to f1 for later use we
have knight capture sunday for queen
captures and now knight to c6 this is
how magnus plans to finish development
later on he can play bishop b7 bishop c5
all depends on what alireza plays now
here alireza says no this is not a
problem i even invite your bishop to c5
you can develop it with tempo on my
queen so magnus does this and now queen
to g3 attacking causing g7 pawn
uh we have castles and now you don't
really gain anything by the immediate
bishop h6 just queen to f6 so alireza
prepares it he plays e5 now there is no
queen to f6 and bishop to h6 is coming
so magnus should probably defend this
with some like f6 or f5 he chooses f5
and now we have e captures on f6 alpha
rook captures on f6 and now bishop to g5
attacking this rook and you can't really
move it because the queen is here uh
however moving it is the only move you
can do so here we reach the position
from the thumbnail rook captures an f2
was played magnus offers a temporary
queen sacrifice but as this bishop is
x-raying that white king uh you are not
gonna uh gets to enjoy this extra queen
to for too long so bishop captures on v8
and now magnus of course goes for rook
to f3 check opens up a discovery and
will win back the queen so king the h1
rook captures on g3 and now alireza not
satisfied with the rook he uh plays
bishop captures on b6 first he wants
magnus to capture on b6 and only then
will he capture the rook uh thus winning
a pawn but magnus says nope you can have
your rook i'm gonna play bishop captures
on b6 and now i have this monster bishop
pair here so uh h captures on g3 there's
really nothing better
and now comes bishop to f2 and this
bishop to f2
is an interesting decision by magnus he
already has this beautiful dash appear
he should rush into and get this rook
into the game to try and somehow maybe
pose more danger to the white king
but he goes for this bishop to have to
move and yes it wins the pawn but it
loses a lot of time and as you will see
it will uh
somewhat discoordinate black's
communication between pieces so rookie 2
bishop caltrason g3 and now knight to e4
attacking the bishop here bishop to e5
and now knight to c5 attacking this
bishop ended the pawn so now the bishop
has to go back to c8 and now the rook
will not
be able to go to f8 but okay later on
maybe you can play rook to b8 but for
the price of one pawn those bishops
aren't really what what they used to be
so here we have c3 biologists not
allowing any uh bishop action along this
diagonal d6 now chasing away the knight
knights the e4 and the king to f7 magnus
starts bringing the king into the game
and now knight g5 check doesn't really
do anything magnus would even give up
this pawn because you don't really want
it if knight captures just bishop b7 the
rook is coming to h8 and you don't
really want to give this open h file to
the to the black rook remember this is
an armageddon game not a lot of time on
the clock so rook to d1 alireza doesn't
waste time he wants to finish
development king the e7 now as the d6
pawn is attacked twice so g3
and now rook to b8 getting that rook
into the game uh we have bishop to g2
getting the bishop to this long diagonal
and now d5 so the e6 pawn is a pass pawn
but there's uh there's a lot of stuff in
between and it's gonna it's not gonna be
easy clearing that so knight to c5 now
this bishop can never move otherwise
rook captures well not for the moment
the bishop is guarding the pawn but this
bishop has to move at some point so it's
a very
tough position for magnus for the moment
we have king to d6 now comes b4
defending the knight we have a4 a5
challenging this b for pawn just a3 we
have a trait here captures captures and
now rook to a8 magnus places the rook on
the newly opened a file knight to e4
check as the d pawn is pinned we have
king back to c7 and now even b5 here
alareza could uh just maybe try and
further hold the position with knight to
c5 but magnus would just repeat and
alireza cannot afford to
uh to repeat moves so he forces uh
this knight to move but of course magnus
doesn't he just plays d captures an e4
and now rook captures an e4 saying that
uh what do you do now you can't really
move the knight you're going to lose the
bishop on e5 so rook to a3 magnus goes
after this pawn you have to give up
something rook to c4 attacking well
rather pinning the attacked piece and
now rook captures on c3 rook captures
bishop captures uh and now even rook to
c1 so really not rushing with uh
winning with the winning back of this
knight uh we have knight to a7 and only
now rook captures on c3 with the czech
king the b6 and now bishop to c6 all it
is it defends his b5 pawn uh and here
you can see that uh
well uh the position is favorable for
alireza he is down upon but he is up the
exchange and if magnus were to capture
on b5 right away uh it's it's not really
a problem because after bishop captures
you don't have to capture right away you
can first deliver this check so you get
the bishop away from the c8 square and
only after the king moves now you pick
up this uh pawn and let's say rook to c7
attacks the bishop and the the the g7
pawn we're going to play bishop to e4
and after rook captures just king to c6
we're going to defend this pawn the
bishop covers the h7 pawn so
white would not have an easy
time trying to win this uh or rather
it's
definitely a draw unless some you know
time issues occur so instead magnus
plays e5 and now king to g1 alareza also
has to start activating his king we have
bishop to f5 and now bishop the e8 so
now the the the bishop is away from the
black king and if you try something like
knight captures on b b5 now rook to b3
attacks
the knight and there is nothing you can
really do about this so magnus continues
with the g6 those pawns and light swords
are now nicely protected you can play h5
at some point king f2 magnus plays h5 uh
we have rook to a3 and now g5 by magnus
so that is this position is better here
even much better but uh
time on the clock is something
definitely to be considered in
armageddon we have rook to a6 with check
kink to b7 you have to keep an eye on
the knight here now comes rook to f6
attacking the bishop here bishop to e4
and now rook to e6 now you're going to
win this pawn so h4 magnus has to hurry
up and create a pass pawn on the king
side the bishop covers the h1 square so
at least he has that going for him g4
already plays it uh
correctly you wanna keep this pawn here
on the dark square and uh this pawn
should not be able to queen so knight
the c8 uh and now comes rook captures on
e5 we have knights to d6 not saying okay
at least you're not going to capture
this because the bishop is hanging uh
and here we have bishop to d7 by alireza
a much quicker way to win this for white
would be rook to e6 just forcing the
trade here if knight captures then you
can capture the
back with the rook or if king to c7 then
you run into this well uh a little trick
and and that's a b6 check so here you
just lose the game the bishop covers the
light squares you have to move and then
rook captures here just completely
winning for alireza but he played bishop
to d7 still winning not a problem uh
king the c7 by magnus and now bishop to
e6
we have bishop back to b7 and now uh he
really should play some like bishop to
d5 uh for force a trade of the light
square bishops or if carlson decides to
move the bishop then he will have
control of the h1 square so he won't
have to worry about this past pawn but
again he plays king to e3 and now he
gives the magnus
a move that uh well that just prevents
alireza from winning the game i'm not
gonna ask you to pause the video to find
this move because you guys know which
move this is but why this is the move
it's a much much uh
a different question so here h3 by
magnus now as like i said the bishop
covers the h1 square and now the real
question is why did alireza play rook
captures on g5 instead of bishop to d5
which just makes sense why why wouldn't
you play this because if uh
if the bishop moves you have control of
the h1 square if bishop captures rook
captures you easily control the h1
square but already decided against this
so why this is so
if bishop to d5 was played feel free to
pause the video and try to figure out
what was carlson's idea here while i
give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on spotting this wild
idea and for those of you who just want
to enjoy the show it's uh it's a
straight out peace sacrifice knight the
sea for check forks the king and the
rook and you have to capture the knight
otherwise you're just gonna lose the
game uh so here bishop captures would
have to be played and now for for a
brief moment the bishop leaves this
diagonal and this is just enough time h2
would be played and now there's really
no way to prevent this past pawn from
queening the rook uh well is boxed in
with the king and this g5 pawn the
bishop if it goes back we just captured
rook captures and we bring the queen
into the game so here we probably see
something like rookie seven check king
to d6 rook to e6 king to c5 and now just
rook to h6 finally going after the pawn
but now h1 queen rook captures and
bishop captures on h1 and here it's just
equal material there is no win here so
this is what alireza missed when he
um
played that all the way back to this
king the ether removed by moving the
queen so far away from the square of the
pawn uh he allowed this h to remove and
then well he he saw that this
this is just insufficient he captured on
g5 but now just h2 and he has to go for
a very similar idea h1 queen rook
captures an h1 bishop captures an h1 and
now he starts of course by pushing g5
he's now down a piece he has to pass
pawns but it doesn't matter to him this
is armageddon it's completely the same
if you uh
lose or draw with the white pieces so
magnus is very happy of course he played
bishop to e4 not allowing this pawn to
go any further king d4 we have bishop to
h7 and now king to e5 magnus just played
knight to the e4 and he was in this
position on move 57 that alireza ferruja
resigned the game as there is nothing
more to be done here or maybe he didn't
resign maybe there maybe they actually
drew the game yeah they agreed to a draw
here uh because it's all the same this
is armageddon and uh if you don't win
with white then you lose with white
uh so and that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it uh so a point each for the
draw in the classical but magnus gets
that extra point for the final standings
extra half a point for the standings uh
because he wins the armageddon game so
he won uh uh see he basically won this
match already that will get his chance
in the second one where magnus will have
the white pieces so could be could be
somewhat more difficult uh but yeah
that's the second game between these two
gentlemen hope you guys enjoyed it i
would like to thank happy 40th birthday
nemo uh david marcus john roberts f
lightheart and sue has roger
chandragupta for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will uh continue covering
this tournament of course checking out
the other games uh checking up on all of
your other wonderful suggestions and
whatever else happens in the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day